When Kirk and his wife MJ evacuated their house in LA on the second day of the fires, they could see the flames up the hill from their backyard. They packed their car full, got their seven and eight-year-old kids inside with the family cat, hit the road. And Kirk started recording.
当柯克和他的妻子 MJ 在火灾发生的第二天从洛杉矶家中撤离时，他们能从后院看到山上的火焰。他们把车塞得满满当当，让七岁和八岁的孩子带着家里的猫坐进去，然后上路了。柯克开始进行录音。
[CRYING]
[哭泣]
OK. Now I know it's scary. But--
好了。现在我知道这很可怕。但是——
Has this happened when Mommy or Daddy was little?
在爸爸妈妈小的时候发生过这种事吗？
He records his kids a lot and just had a feeling like this is an important moment.
他经常录下孩子们的生活，当时他只是觉得这是一个重要的时刻。
Can we just drive to a song by the Beatles?
我们开车的时候能放一首披头士的歌吗？
Sure.
当然可以。
Not a rock band, OK?
不要放摇滚乐队的，好吗？
Sure.
没问题。
Just like "Hey Jude" maybe?
比如《Hey Jude》怎么样？
Not like We the Kings because I don't really want to listen to rock.
不要像 We the Kings 那种，因为我真的不想听摇滚。
OK, but can I just say something?
好的，但我能说一句话吗？
OK, can I say something? I don't really want to listen to rock music when our house is going to--
好吧，我能说点什么吗？当我们的房子快要……的时候，我真的不想听摇滚乐。
OK.
好的。
--burn down.
……被烧毁。
Our house is OK. Our house is going to be OK, OK?
我们的房子没事的。我们的房子会没事的，好吗？
Kirk is Kirk Johnson. He's been on our show before, talking about his experiences in the Iraq War, among other things. He thinks of himself as somebody who can usually handle a moment of crisis.
柯克是柯克·约翰逊。他以前上过我们的节目，谈论过他在伊拉克战争中的经历以及其他事情。他认为自己是一个通常能处理危机时刻的人。
But he admits, he made mistakes in the car. He didn't bring the family tortoise, an animal he says his kids have ignored for over a year. It lives in a giant crate outside the house. In the car, he realized how upset his son August was about that.
但他承认，他在车里犯了错误。他没带家里的陆龟，他说孩子们已经有一年多没理会这只宠物了。它住在屋外的巨大板条箱里。在车里，他意识到儿子奥古斯特对此感到多么难过。
But they drove. Looked at wind speeds and wind directions, made a guess about where it might be safe, booked a hotel. And things were feeling a little calmer in the car.
但他们还是开车走了。观察风速和风向，推测哪里可能安全，并预订了一家酒店。车里的气氛感觉稍微平静了一些。
Daddy, can you tell us one of your kids' stories you haven't told us?
爸爸，你能给我们讲一个你以前没讲过的关于你小时候的故事吗？
Yeah, that's a good idea, I guess.
好吧，我想这是个好主意。
That's August asking Kirk to tell a story from his childhood, which he does sometimes. Kirk grew up with chickens, goats, and animals.
那是奥古斯特要求柯克讲他童年的故事，他有时会这么做。柯克是在鸡、山羊和其他动物的陪伴下长大的。
OK. Did I ever tell you the story about-- I think I did-- when my horse got sick?
好吧。我给你讲过……我想讲过，关于我的马生病的故事吗？
No, you never told us that.
不，你从来没讲过。
I used to have a horse named Joe.
我以前有一匹马叫乔。
Yep. I like to think--
没错。我喜欢认为——
Let's just make his last name Biden, OK?
我们还是给它加上姓氏拜登吧，好吗？
Joe Biden.
乔·拜登。
And the Joe Biden.
还有那匹乔·拜登。
Joe Biden the horse. And Mamie and Gramps went to visit Uncle Sorin in Russia. But they were far away, and they left me home alone. I was like--
乔·拜登这匹马。玛米和爷爷去俄罗斯看望索林叔叔了。他们离得很远，把我一个人留在了家里。我当时……
Wait, how old were you?
等等，你那时多大？
14 or 15. And one day, I went down to check on Joe one morning before school. And he was lying on the ground. He was kneeling down, which is not a good sign for a horse. And I didn't know what to do.
14 或 15 岁。有一天早上上学前，我下楼去查看乔。它躺在地上。它跪着，这对马来说不是好兆头。我不知道该怎么办。
And so I went to school, and then I came back. And I was really nervous, and Joe was still lying on the ground. And every day I was trying to get him to eat food and stuff. And he wasn't eating anything. And so you know what I did? Do you know what my best idea was?
于是我去上学了，然后又回来了。我真的很紧张，乔还是躺在地上。每天我都试着让它吃东西之类的。但它什么都不吃。你知道我做了什么吗？你知道我最好的主意是什么吗？
What?
什么？
I started digging a grave next to Joe, like a big hole, a little bit every day so that if he died, there would be a big hole right next to him. That was my smart idea.
我开始在乔旁边挖一个坟墓，就像一个大坑，每天挖一点点，这样如果它死了，它旁边就有一个大坑了。那就是我聪明的想法。
And then Mamie and Gramps got home, and they're like, what are you doing? I was like, I'm digging a grave for Joe. And they're like, why don't you just call the veterinarian? And the veterinarian came and gave him a shot, and he was totally fine. But after that, Joe kind of looked at me a little funny.
后来玛米和爷爷回到家，他们问，你在做什么？我说，我在给乔挖坟墓。他们说，你为什么不直接给兽医打电话呢？兽医来了，给它打了一针，它完全好了。但从那以后，乔看我的眼神有点奇怪。
What was the moment you realized, oh, this is not the right story for this moment?
你意识到“哦，在这个时候讲这个故事不合适”是在哪个瞬间？
Well, when I realized it was a creature that I was-- a beloved pet of ours that I was convinced was about to die.
嗯，当我意识到它是我们心爱的宠物，而且我当时确信它快要死的时候。
And digging a grave for him.
而且还给它挖了坟墓。
But halfway through, I realized, oh, god, I'm getting them right into death, and dying, and uncertainty about how to handle a situation. How do I get out of this?
但讲到一半时，我意识到，天哪，我正把他们带向死亡、垂死，以及关于如何处理这种情况的不确定性中。我该怎么脱身呢？
I don't really want to talk about, like, dying and graves right now.
我现在真的不想谈论死亡和坟墓之类的话题。
Sorry. Oh, yeah. OK, let's--
对不起。哦，是的。好吧，让我们……
It's OK, Daddy.
没事的，爸爸。
Sorry, I shouldn't have told the Joe.
对不起，我不该讲那个乔的故事。
It's OK.
没关系。
I rode that horse all the time.
我以前一直骑那匹马。
Kirk and his family were lucky, unlike so many families in Los Angeles right now. They're now back in their home. The tortoise is fine.
柯克和他的家人很幸运，不像现在洛杉矶的许多家庭。他们现在已经回到了家中。那只陆龟也很好。
But in that moment, when it was so unclear what to do, and he and his wife MJ were trying to pretend that things were going to be fine when they really had no idea at all and were scared they were not going to be fine, when his brain searched for a story to tell the children, this one with the horse is the one that popped up.
但在那一刻，当完全不清楚该做什么时，当他和妻子 MJ 试图假装一切都会好起来，而实际上他们完全不知道，并且害怕事情不会好起来时，当他的大脑寻找一个故事讲给孩子们听时，关于那匹马的故事就这样浮现了出来。
And if I really think about it, that story is about decision-making without enough information. I didn't know what to do. And the best idea I came up with was just impossibly stupid. But yeah, the moral of that story is like, sometimes, you choose poorly.
如果我仔细想想，那个故事是关于在信息不足的情况下如何做决策。我不知道该怎么办。我想到的最好主意竟然如此愚蠢。但是是的，那个故事的寓意是，有时候，你的选择会很糟糕。
These kind of moments, when you feel the Earth shifting underneath you, and you just have to figure out what you're going to do in this new reality, that's what our show is about today-- people with different pivot points in their lives, between what was and what's about to happen. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这种时刻，当你感觉到脚下的地球在震动，而你必须弄清楚在这个新现实中该怎么做时，这就是我们今天节目要讨论的主题——人们生命中的转折点，介于过去和即将发生之间。来自芝加哥 WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
This American Life, Act One, Who's Laughing Now? So we start today with this story about somebody who's been thinking a lot about one particular pivot point that the world might go through. Nancy Updike went to meet him.
《美国生活》，第一幕，谁在笑？所以我们今天从这个故事开始，讲一个一直在思考世界可能经历的某个特定转折点的人。南希·厄普代克去见了他。
Got a question for you out there listening-- have you ever had a bloody nose? I ask because I got a bloody nose recently, when I went to do an interview with a British comedy writer and director named Armando Iannucci.
问一下正在收听的各位——你们有没有流过鼻血？我问这个问题是因为我最近在去采访一位名叫阿曼多·伊安努奇的英国喜剧作家兼导演时流鼻血了。
He made the TV show Veep for HBO, now MAX, with Julia Louis-Dreyfus playing the vice president. He made a movie called The Death of Stalin, a comedy-- somehow-- about the battle for succession in the Soviet Union after Stalin died. And he made a movie that I especially love called In the Loop, about the lead-up to a war that isn't identified as the Iraq War, but seems a lot like the Iraq War-- also a comedy.
他为 HBO（现在是 MAX）制作了电视剧《副总统》，由朱莉娅·路易斯-德莱弗斯饰演副总统。他拍了一部电影叫《斯大林的葬礼》，这是一部关于斯大林死后苏联继承权之争的喜剧——不知何故。他还拍了一部我特别喜欢的电影叫《灵通人士》，讲述了一场未被认定为伊拉克战争、但看起来很像伊拉克战争的战争前夕——也是一部喜剧。
Armando Iannucci gets called prescient a lot, but I think of him not so much as prescient as in tune. He follows the news. He is paying attention to now. Veep got into aspects of the political culture in Washington in a way no other show did-- the epic pettiness, the unglamorous maneuvering. I'm always interested to see, through his work, what he finds funny, and relevant, and sometimes frightening in the world.
阿曼多·伊安努奇经常被称为有先见之明，但我认为他与其说是有先见之明，不如说是合拍。他关注新闻。他关注现在。《副总统》以其他节目无法比拟的方式展现了华盛顿政治文化的方方面面——史诗般的琐碎，以及毫无魅力可言的权谋。我一直很感兴趣通过他的作品，去看看他在世界上发现了什么有趣、相关且有时令人恐惧的东西。
So I went to London to interview him about one of his new projects, a new play, which I will get to. But right now, all you need to know is that I came to the interview as a fan, straight up. I didn't hide it, but I didn't lead with it either. We were both there to do our jobs.
所以我去了伦敦采访他关于他的一个新项目，一部新剧，我稍后会提到。但现在，你只需要知道我是带着粉丝的心态去采访的，坦率地说。我没有掩饰这一点，但我也没有以此为开头。我们都在那里履行各自的职责。
I was told I would get an hour with him. To be safe, I was 15 minutes early. And while I was waiting, I got a bloody nose. I got the bloody nose while I was standing in the living room, type room, somewhere upstairs, at the Noel Coward Theater in London, a room that has a white carpet, and white upholstered chairs, and a silver upholstered couch.
我被告知会有一个小时的采访时间。为了保险起见，我早到了 15 分钟。在等待的时候，我流鼻血了。我流鼻血时正站在伦敦诺埃尔·考沃德剧院楼上的一个起居室类型的房间里，那个房间有白色的地毯、白色的软垫椅子和银色的软垫沙发。
I pulled a bunch of tissues from my bag-- pretty much always have tissues. And I was holding a pile of them to my bloody nose. Normal-- it happens. I get bloody noses sometimes. Then I ran out of tissues. So I started using paper towels from the kitchenette that was attached to the living room. And it was a lot of blood.
我从包里拿出了一堆纸巾——我基本上总是带着纸巾。我把一大叠纸巾按在流血的鼻子上。很正常——这事时有发生。我有时会流鼻血。然后我的纸巾用完了。所以我开始用起居室附属小厨房里的纸巾。血流了很多。
So I had a big wad of paper towels pressed to my nose, trying not to drip on the white rug, when Armando Iannucci walked through the kitchenette and into the living room. He and the publicist were concerned. He said, do you need a few minutes? He understood about bloody noses.
所以我用一大团纸巾按住鼻子，尽量不滴在地毯上，这时阿曼多·伊安努奇穿过小厨房走进起居室。他和公关人员都很担心。他说，你需要几分钟吗？他理解流鼻血这回事。
The publicist said, would you like to use the toilet? I said, yes, that would be great. Thank you so much. I am so sorry about this. Where is that toilet? And I went to the bathroom to wrap this mess up.
公关人员说，你想用一下洗手间吗？我说，是的，那太好了。非常感谢。真的很抱歉。洗手间在哪？我走进洗手间去收拾这个烂摊子。
And I had what seemed to be a rolling series of bloody noses or one big one that had many phases-- I don't know. But what I do know from sad, gross experience is that a bloody nose means there's a clot somewhere high up in my nose that needs to come out for the bloody nose to stop.
我经历了一连串的流鼻血，或者是一次持续很长时间的大出血——我不知道。但我从悲伤而恶心的经验中知道的是，流鼻血意味着鼻子里高处有个血块，需要排出来鼻血才会停止。
So I was trying to blow my nose and blow the clot out, and it took me some time to realize that as I was doing that-- unsuccessfully-- I was spraying tiny droplets of blood all over-- the sink, the toilet seat, the floor, the mirror, the wallpaper-- the wallpaper.
所以我试着擤鼻子把血块弄出来，我花了一段时间才意识到，在我做这件事的同时——并没有成功——我把细小的血滴溅得到处都是——水槽、马桶座圈、地板、镜子、墙纸——墙纸上。
I started wiping everywhere like it was a crime scene. And I rolled up a tight, little roll of toilet paper and stuck it up my right nostril to catch the blood. That's what I do at home when I have a bloody nose and no one's looking. And the little roll of toilet paper filled with blood and fell on the floor as I was wiping the floor.
我开始到处擦拭，就像犯罪现场一样。我把卫生纸紧紧揉成一个小球，塞进右鼻孔里吸血。我在家流鼻血且没人在场时就是这么做的。那个沾满血的小纸球在我擦地板时掉在了地上。
I had to roll up another one. That filled with blood. Roll up a new one, take out the old one. Repeat, repeat. I went through an entire roll of toilet paper and had to start a new one. So I was pacing around this little bathroom with toilet paper in my nose, looking for tiny blood drops, and muttering to myself, you gotta wrap this up. Wrap it up. Wrap this up. And time was passing.
我不得不又揉了一个。那个也被血填满了。再揉一个新的，把旧的拿出来。重复，重复。我用掉了一整卷卫生纸，不得不开始用新的一卷。所以我在这个小洗手间里踱步，鼻子里塞着卫生纸，寻找着细小的血点，嘟囔着，你必须快点结束。快点。搞定它。时间就这样流逝了。
So I started thinking, maybe I could interview Armando Iannucci with rolled up toilet paper sticking out of my nose. Or-- or-- maybe I could stick a really tiny bit of toilet paper far enough up my nose that he wouldn't see it, but it would still block the blood.
所以我开始想，也许我可以用鼻子里塞着揉成团的卫生纸去采访阿曼多·伊安努奇。或者——或者——也许我可以把一小块卫生纸塞得够深，让他看不到，但又能堵住血。
This nosebleed went on for half an hour. It was a full-on anxiety dream come to life. And Armando Iannucci's movies and TV shows are full of awkward scenes that happen on the job-- a person trying to do a serious thing and getting thwarted by something dumb and embarrassing, like a pair of squeaky shoes. In one of his movies, an assistant secretary of state starts bleeding from her teeth in the middle of a meeting.
这次鼻出血持续了半个小时。这简直是焦虑梦境照进现实。阿曼多·伊安努奇的电影和电视剧里充满了工作中的尴尬场面——一个人试图做一件严肃的事，却被一些愚蠢而尴尬的事情所挫败，比如一双会吱吱作响的鞋子。在他的一部电影中，一位助理国务卿在会议中牙齿开始出血。
And what usually happens in these scenes is the person just gets pounced on, mocked without mercy by their colleagues, or rivals, or the press. Any vulnerability or misstep is noticed and weaponized.
而这些场景中通常发生的情况是，那个人会遭到同事、竞争对手或媒体的毫不留情的嘲笑。任何脆弱或失误都会被发现并被武器化。
But Armando Iannucci, the real person, in real life, did something completely different. I walked out of the bathroom, not even sure the interview was still possible. So much time had been lost. And he said, with perfect grace, I'm not in a rush.
但现实生活中的阿曼多·伊安努奇，做得完全不同。我走出洗手间时，甚至不确定采访是否还能进行。时间已经浪费了太多。他极其优雅地说，我不着急。
He and the publicist, Nada, simply put the whole thing behind us. Nada said, look, he's got a photo shoot in half an hour, but he can come back after that. Armando said, we'll talk for a while. And then I'll go and come back, and we'll talk more. It was like he waved a wand over me and said, you had a nightmare, and now it's over-- which is the opposite of what happens in his new play.
他和公关人员娜达简单地把这一切抛在脑后。娜达说，你看，他半小时后有个拍摄，但他之后可以回来。阿曼多说，我们聊一会儿。然后我去处理一下再回来，我们继续聊。就像他对我挥了挥魔杖说，你做了一场噩梦，现在结束了——这与他的新剧中发生的事情恰恰相反。
I wanted to interview Armando because his work is so good at capturing things about now, about the present. And I saw that he was doing a stage version of an old Cold War film, Dr. Strangelove by Stanley Kubrick. And I found it alarming that this was his next project. I mean, it's a comedy, but the last scene is nuclear armageddon and the end of the world.
我想采访阿曼多是因为他的作品非常擅长捕捉当下的事物。我看到他正在制作一部旧冷战电影的舞台版，斯坦利·库布里克的《奇爱博士》。我发现这是他的下一个项目令人担忧。我是说，这是一部喜剧，但最后一幕是核末日和世界末日。
So what did he see in it that spoke to him about now? Why choose that particular story out of all possible stories at this moment? Well, part of the answer to why now is someone asked.
那么他在其中看到了什么与当下相关的东西？为什么在这个时刻从所有可能的故事中选择了这个特定故事？嗯，为什么是现在的答案的一部分是有人提议了。
Well, Dr. Strangelove is one of those films that's it's always been in my top five movies of all time.
嗯，《奇爱博士》是我有史以来最喜欢的五部电影之一。
Ladies and gentlemen, Armando Iannucci. He got a call from the director and co-adapter of the play, Sean Foley, who asked Armando, did he want to work on it with him? And Armando quickly said, yes.
女士们先生们，阿曼多·伊安努奇。他接到了该剧导演兼联合改编肖恩·福利的电话，问阿曼多是否想和他一起制作。阿曼多很快说，好。
I think it's the best dark comedy film ever made. I'm a huge Kubrick fan. The other reason I said yes was because-- and this was several years ago-- at the time, climate change was becoming a much more stark reality. There was a kind of a sensation of, if we don't do something immediately about this, the world isn't going to come back from it, that sense of us as a collective species still being unable to save ourselves from our own behavior.
我认为这是有史以来最好的黑色喜剧电影。我是库布里克的超级粉丝。我答应的另一个原因是——那是几年前——当时，气候变化正在成为一个更严峻的现实。有一种感觉，如果我们不立即对此采取行动，世界将无法恢复，这种作为人类集体物种却无法拯救自己免受自身行为影响的感觉。
Us, as a species, being unable to save ourselves from our own behavior is the plot of Dr. Strangelove. The entire story lives in the minutes right before the world pivots from a planet full of life to a deathscape of ashes and poison.
我们作为一个物种，无法拯救自己免受自身行为的影响，这就是《奇爱博士》的情节。整个故事发生在世界从一个充满生命的星球转变为毒药灰烬的死亡之地前的几分钟。
The story is an American general goes quietly nuts. He's a conspiracy theorist who believes commies are poisoning America through fluoridation. To stop that, he sends US bombers off to start a nuclear war with the Soviet Union.
故事是一位美国将军悄悄疯了。他是一个阴谋论者，认为共产党人正通过氟化作用毒害美国。为了阻止这一点，他派出美国轰炸机去引发与苏联的核战争。
When reasonable people on both sides realize what's happening, they try to stop it. The US president gets so desperate that he gives the Soviets the information they need to shoot down the planes. But one bomber gets through anyway, triggering a cascade of nuclear bombs to fire automatically, destroying the world.
当双方的理智人士意识到发生了什么时，他们试图阻止。美国总统非常绝望，以至于他给了苏联人击落飞机所需的信息。但一架轰炸机还是漏网了，触发了核弹自动发射的连锁反应，摧毁了世界。
Everyone on stage realizes there's a good chance the world might end, but they can't quite admit it. It's like a very slow-motion car crash that you're watching. And everyone's caught up in it, but unable to because of their own desire to retain their own status and to prove their point over the enemy, leading to annihilation.
舞台上的每个人都意识到世界有很大可能终结，但他们无法完全承认。这就像你正在观看的一场极慢动作的车祸。每个人都被卷入其中，但由于他们各自想要保持地位和向敌人证明自己观点而无法阻止，最终导致了灭绝。
More than any one-to-one correspondence with the news now, there's a feeling to Strangelove that I found familiar, a sense that enormous danger is looming, but we're also wading through a sludge of ridiculousness. I feel some level of dread all the time for a while now. And I had a hunch, based on Armando's work, that he might have a similar feeling.
比起与现在新闻的任何一对一对应，我发现《奇爱博士》有一种熟悉的感觉，一种巨大的危险迫在眉睫，但我们同时也陷在荒谬的泥潭中。我有一段时间一直感到某种程度的恐惧。根据阿曼多的作品，我有一种预感，他可能也有类似的感觉。
Oh, absolutely. Yeah, dread-- yes. I think we're all anxious about something, but for each person, it's a different thing, or we can't quite put a finger on it. There's just a cumulative atmosphere of dread and foreboding, but not quite knowing what--
哦，绝对。是的，恐惧——是的。我想我们都在为某些事情感到焦虑，但对每个人来说，事情各不相同，或者我们说不清楚是什么。只是一种累积的恐惧和预感，但又不知道究竟是什么……
I mean, was it a way for you to channel-- to organize or contain your own dread as a project?
我的意思是，这是一种让你引导——组织或包含你自己恐惧的项目方式吗？
Oh, absolutely. It's a way of articulating it. It's a way of processing it. Or it's a way of dramatizing it.
哦，绝对。这是一种表达方式。这是一种处理方式。或者说这是一种戏剧化它的方式。
Once I got an answer to why make Strangelove now, we moved into a meandery but very enjoyable conversation about how to confront your dread these days, because I am taking suggestions, and Armando's work is something I've returned to again and again.
一旦我得到了为什么现在制作《奇爱博士》的答案，我们便进入了一段曲折但非常愉快的对话，讨论如何应对这些日子的恐惧，因为我正在征求建议，而阿曼多的作品是我一次又一次回过头来研读的。
And what I'm thinking now is that, especially with his movies and with Strangelove, I come for the comedy, but maybe stay for the dread. So we talked about how do you go about making comedy out of catastrophe and fear?
我现在在想的是，特别是他的电影和《奇爱博士》，我为喜剧而来，但也许因恐惧而停留。所以我们讨论了如何将灾难和恐惧转化为喜剧？
You've said that people underestimate comedy, which I agree, especially about things that are big and terrifying. But make the case. What do people underestimate its ability to do that you feel like, no, no, it's best? It's best at that?
你说过人们低估了喜剧，我同意，特别是在涉及重大且可怕的事情时。但请陈述理由。人们低估了它的什么能力，让你觉得，不，不，它是最棒的？它在处理这些方面最棒？
I'm not arguing comedy is better. It just gives you another way in. And I think comedy, I think it just allows you to open up your mind a bit. If you find yourself laughing at something and then asking yourself, should I have laughed at that? Or-- well, well, if you've laughed at it, then you should. It's spontaneous. I think that's why autocratic leaders hate jokes about themselves because--
我并不是在争论喜剧更好。它只是给你提供了另一种进入的方式。我认为喜剧，它只是让你稍微打开心扉。如果你发现自己对某事笑了，然后问自己，我不该笑吗？或者——好吧，如果你已经笑了，那你确实应该笑。它是自发的。我认为这就是独裁领导人讨厌关于他们自己的笑话的原因，因为……
Yeah, they're spontaneous. They can't control it or predict it.
是的，它们是自发的。他们无法控制或预测。
It's out of their hands. They like stuff where they could tell you what to do. And comedy allows what might otherwise feel forbidding and inaccessible theme. It allows you that entry point. Before making The Death of Stalin, I went back and watched The Great Dictator.
这超出了他们的掌控。他们喜欢那些他们可以告诉你要做什么的东西。而喜剧允许进入原本可能让人觉得禁忌且无法触及的主题。它为你提供了那个切入点。在制作《斯大林的葬礼》之前，我回去看了《大独裁者》。
The Great Dictator is a movie about Hitler that Charlie Chaplin put out, incredibly, in 1940.
《大独裁者》是查理·卓别林在 1940 年令人难以置信地推出的关于希特勒的电影。
So not even with the benefit of hindsight-- right in the middle of it. And he treads this line between high comedy-- fantastic, memorable comedic moments like Adenoid Hynkel, the dictator, just playing with a globe, picking Earth up in his hands and dancing with it, and then scenes set in the Jewish ghetto, which are not funny, not meant to be funny. And it's this balance between the funny and the tragic.
所以甚至都没有事后诸葛亮的好处——就处在其中。他走在高级喜剧——精彩、令人难忘的喜剧时刻，比如独裁者阿德诺伊德·辛克尔只是玩弄一个地球仪，把地球捧在手里跳舞，以及设定在犹太隔都的场景，那些场景并不好笑，也不打算好笑。这就是幽默与悲剧之间的平衡。
And I knew when going into The Death of Stalin, that's what I wanted to do. And I said to everyone when we started filming, I said to the crew and to the cast, it's a comedy, but we must also be mindful and respectful of what happened to the people. We're not making fun of the deaths and the punishments they were making. The comedy comes from those inside the Kremlin. And it was holding those two tones and moods simultaneously.
在开始《斯大林的葬礼》时，我知道这就是我想要做的。我开始拍摄时对每个人说，我对剧组和演员说，这是一部喜剧，但我们也必须留心并尊重那些发生在人民身上的事。我们不是在取笑他们所做的死亡和惩罚。喜剧来自克里姆林宫内部。那是同时保持这两种基调和情绪。
Armando pulls it off because he doesn't skimp on either the bad in The Death of Stalin or the comedy. The bad is quite bad, and the funny is really funny. And one way I've noticed that he keeps those two moods aloft at the same time in many of his projects, he often focuses on people who work together.
阿曼多做到了，因为他在《斯大林的葬礼》中的邪恶或喜剧方面都没有吝啬。邪恶确实非常邪恶，而有趣的部分确实非常有趣。我注意到他在许多项目中保持这两种情绪同时存在的一种方式是，他经常关注一起工作的人。
In The Death of Stalin, there's this intense rivalry among the men around Stalin, all jockeying for power after he dies, scheming, and whingeing, and flailing. That workplace power struggle is what made Veep so funny, too.
在《斯大林的葬礼》中，斯大林周围的人之间存在激烈的竞争，都在他死后争权夺利，阴谋算计，抱怨，挣扎。那种职场权力斗争也使《副总统》如此有趣。
In the Strangelove play, the president and his advisors are in the war room, gathered around a ludicrously large, circular table, mostly arguing. And one guy, a guy you may know from your own job, keeps throwing out bad ideas in a loud voice, in a sort of Roman Roy, "I'm the only one being real here" way.
在《奇爱博士》的戏中，总统和他的顾问在作战室里，围坐在一张荒谬巨大的圆桌旁，大多在争论。一个人，一个你可能在自己的工作中认识的人，不断大声抛出坏主意，用一种像罗曼·罗伊那种“我是这里唯一真实的人”的方式。
For instance, he argues that maybe the thing to do is to lean into this attack the US has launched. Not bring back the bombers that are on their way, but send more planes with more bombs. Try to win this war, rather than try to stop it. It all makes sense under something called Plan R.
例如，他认为也许该做的是顺应美国发动的这次攻击。不要召回已经在路上的轰炸机，而是派更多的飞机带着更多的炸弹。试图赢得这场战争，而不是试图阻止它。在所谓“R计划”下，这一切都说得通。
It would remove all uncertainty if we pretaliate.
如果我们先发制人，这将消除所有不确定性。
Pretali what?
先发制什么？
Pretaliate. I think this is a new word.
先发制人。我认为这是一个新词。
See, conventionally, if the Russians attack us, our only option is to--
看，按照常规，如果俄国人攻击我们，我们唯一的选择就是……
Retaliate!
还击！
Plan R gives us a second option. We pretaliate before they even think of taliating. Nuclear preterrence, sir, in a nutshell. It's bulletproof.
R计划给了我们第二个选择。我们在他们想到还击之前就先发制人。简而言之，核先发制人，长官。这是万无一失的。
Pretaliate isn't in the Strangelove movie, but it was built out of logic that is in there, and that Armando and the director and co-adaptor Sean Foley expanded and riffed on.
先发制人不在《奇爱博士》电影中，但它是建立在其中的逻辑之上，阿曼多和导演兼联合改编肖恩·福利扩展并即兴发挥了它。
I've spent the last whatever-- [LAUGHS] several decades examining politicians, their speech, and how they use rhetoric to disguise or to pretend something is not what it is and so on.
我花了过去……[笑] 几十年的时间来研究政客、他们的言论，以及他们如何使用修辞来掩饰或假装某事不是它看起来的样子等等。
But Armando says, sometimes, you really don't need to riff or invent. Sometimes comedy is just sitting there, waiting to be picked up, like a $100 bill on the sidewalk.
但阿曼多说，有时候，你真的不需要即兴发挥或发明。有时候喜剧就坐在那里，等着被捡起来，就像人行道上的一张 100 美元钞票。
In the film, it opens with the Air Force gate saying, "Peace is our profession." I thought that was a gag. I thought Kubrick made it up. In the archive, you come in. There's the photo. It exists.
在电影中，它以空军大门上的字开头，“和平是我们的职业”。我以为那是个梗。我以为是库布里克编出来的。在档案里，你进去。照片就在那里。它确实存在。
This is in the Kubrick archive, he says.
这是在库布里克档案中，他说。
He saw this photo of an Air Force base with "Peace is our profession" written on it. So again, he's taking what's true and just putting it in, you know?
他看到了这张写着“和平是我们的职业”的空军基地照片。所以同样，他在提取真实的东西并把它放进去，你知道吗？
Yeah, "Peace is our profession" shows up a bunch of times in the movie, along with other funny sight gags of just the way things are labeled. And I thought-- I thought "peace is our profession" was over the top. I thought, oh, it's too much.
是的，“和平是我们的职业”在电影中出现了好几次，还有其他有趣的视觉梗，只是关于事情被标记的方式。我想——我想“和平是我们的职业”太过分了。我想，哦，那太夸张了。
I know. And it was real. It was real. I know. I know. And that's when you just think, you don't have to embroider it. If what is true makes the point, then make that point with the truth. With The Death of Stalin, as we researched the story, we kept finding more and more stories that were just absurd, but actually happened.
我知道。而且它是真实的。它是真实的。我知道。我知道。那就是你只会觉得，你不需要润色它。如果真实的事实能说明问题，那就用真相来说明。在制作《斯大林的葬礼》时，随着我们研究这个故事，我们不断发现越来越多虽然荒谬但确实发生过的故事。
Like a scene that ended up in the movie about Stalin's son, Vasili.
比如电影中关于斯大林的儿子瓦西里的一个场景。
Vasili was high up in the Soviet Air Force. He was overpromoted. He was drunk. He was in charge of the ice hockey team. He sent them to a tournament in an ice storm. He was warned there'd be a danger to the flight. The flight went down. He lost the ice hockey team. He was too scared to tell his father, so he just recruited friends of friends for a new team, who were terrible.
瓦西里在苏联空军担任高级职务。他晋升过快。他酗酒。他负责冰球队。他在冰风暴中派他们去参加比赛。有人警告他飞行会有危险。飞机坠毁了。他失去了冰球队。他太害怕不敢告诉他父亲，所以他只是为新球队招募了朋友的朋友，他们水平很差。
And that's such a bizarre story, but it says so much about even his son was scared of him. And that's what I'm saying. It's all about the truth, you know? It's the truth of what people really felt at the time. How can we get to that, that uneasy feeling they had at the bottom of the stomach for years, that they might be rounded up and taken away in the middle of the night?
那是一个如此离奇的故事，但它充分说明了甚至连他的儿子都怕他。这就是我所说的。这完全是关于真相，你知道吗？这是当时人们真实感受的真相。我们如何才能触及那种他们多年来内心深处有的不安感，他们可能会在半夜被围捕并带走？
I've now seen Dr. Strangelove a bunch of times, the movie and then the play, and every time I think, so no one wins in the end, the bad ideas don't prevail. Nothingness prevails. It's shocking. Many times in my life, I've looked back at a specific moment and thought, oh right, that was before, before I knew that, before this happened.
我已经看过好多次《奇爱博士》了，电影还有舞台剧，每次我都想，所以最后没有人赢，坏主意并没有获胜。虚无获胜了。这太令人震惊了。在我的一生中，我多次回顾某个特定的时刻并想，哦对了，那是在之前，在我知道那个之前，在这件事发生之前。
But it's much more unsettling to experience now, the moment you are currently in, as that before time. To look around and feel that you will look back on this moment as one that came before so many losses or changes or hardships. Dr. Strangelove, the play, gave the audience a chance to, sure, laugh, but also to feel that dread, to see ourselves as living in a time before, before something. It's not clear what.
但更让人不安的是现在去体验，你目前所处的时刻，作为那个之前的时间。四处看看，感觉到你以后回首这一刻，会觉得它发生在这么多损失、变化或苦难之前。舞台剧《奇爱博士》给了观众一个机会，当然可以笑，但也能感受到那种恐惧，看到我们自己生活在一种之前的时间里，在某种东西之前。不清楚是什么。
Nuclear bombs have a narrative advantage that way. They have one iconic image associated with them-- a recognizable brand of destruction. What is the right image for what's on our horizon-- or mine? I'll just speak for myself, my dread. I rewatched the movie and saw the play during the hottest year on record, in the summer before the US presidential election.
核弹在这方面有一个叙事优势。它们与一个标志性的形象相关联——一种可识别的毁灭品牌。什么是我们地平线上——或者我的地平线上——的正确形象？我就代表我自己，我的恐惧。我在有记录以来最热的一年，在美国总统大选前的夏天重温了这部电影并观看了这场戏。
I'm writing this story wondering how much of Los Angeles is going to burn and whether there's going to be a nationwide ban on abortion, mass deportations. I don't have a picture in my head to focus on. It feels more like a play-- a lot of dialogue, and I'm experiencing it live.
我写这个故事时想知道洛杉矶会有多少地方被烧毁，是否会有全国性的堕胎禁令、大规模驱逐。我脑子里没有一个可以聚焦的画面。它感觉更像一场戏——有很多对话，而且我正在现场体验它。
Nancy Updike is a producer on our show.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制片人。
The stage version of Dr. Strangelove-- which, by the way, stars Steve Coogan in several different roles-- is playing at the Noel Coward Theater in London through January 25 and will be in Dublin from February 5 to February 22.
舞台版《奇爱博士》——顺便说一句，由史蒂夫·库根主演多个不同角色——正在伦敦诺埃尔·考沃德剧院上演至 1 月 25 日，并将于 2 月 5 日至 2 月 22 日在都柏林演出。
Act Two, The View from the Dugout. So one of the things that seems likely to change once Donald Trump is, again, in the White House is US policy toward Ukraine. His vice president, JD Vance, has called for an end to aid to Ukraine and describe a peace plan that basically lets Russia keep the territory it's gained. Donald Trump has been vaguer about his intentions, but he's been a skeptic of continued aid. He has said many times that he was going to end the war in 24 hours.
第二幕，从战壕看出去。一旦唐纳德·特朗普再次入主白宫，似乎很可能会改变的事情之一就是美国的乌克兰政策。他的副总统 JD·万斯呼吁停止对乌克兰的援助，并描述了一项基本上让俄罗斯保留其获得的领土的和平计划。唐纳德·特朗普对他的意图一直含糊其辞，但他对继续提供援助持怀疑态度。他多次表示他会在 24 小时内结束战争。
We wondered what it's like for Ukrainian soldiers, who depend on US arms right now, to see all of this at this pivot point, and how they're imagining what's going to happen next once Trump takes office. Our producer, Valerie Kipnis, spoke with a bunch of people on the front lines.
我们想知道目前依赖美国武器的乌克兰士兵看到这一切时是什么感觉，在这个转折点，他们如何想象特朗普上任后会发生什么。我们的制片人瓦莱丽·基普尼斯与前线的许多人进行了交谈。
The first soldier I want to tell you about is Serhei. He's a former vegan chef from Kyiv. He'd quit his job to join the army a year ago. He's really proud of the fact that his unit recycles.
我要告诉你们的第一个士兵是谢尔盖。他曾是基辅的素食厨师。他一年前辞职参军。他真的很自豪他的部队会回收利用。
When I asked how he described what his unit looks like when they're in action, he said, like Hobbits in a bunker, Hobbits with mortars. Serhei told me that it's a strange feeling to live in this moment of time before things might change. Everyone around him believes in anything and everything, all at the same time. There's nothing that's not in the realm of possibility.
当我问他如何描述他们的部队在行动时的样子时，他说，就像碉堡里的霍比特人，带着迫击炮的霍比特人。谢尔盖告诉我，生活在这个事情可能发生变化的时刻是一种奇怪的感觉。他周围的每个人都在同一时间相信任何事情。没有什么是超出了可能性的范围。
I've definitely felt like-- and still might feel-- like time has stopped. Time has stopped. And something needs to happen.
我绝对觉得——并且可能仍然觉得——时间停止了。时间停止了。并且有些事情需要发生。
Like right now, you're living in the part of time that's stopped.
就像现在，你生活在时间停止的那部分里。
Definitely, definitely. Everything simultaneously, like with this. Everything is real. Everything might be real. Everything might happen. So there is no reasons why tomorrow or in a week, whole Europe, and UK, and the US might not decide behind closed doors and just provide Ukraine with a decision to stop military funding. And of course, that would be a huge impact on our ability to keep on fighting. Oh, one second, one second. Let me-- here if you'll hear it.
绝对，绝对。一切同时发生，就像这个一样。一切都是真实的。一切都可能是真实的。一切都可能发生。所以没有理由说明天或者一周后，整个欧洲、英国和美国不会在闭门造车的情况下做出决定，直接向乌克兰提供停止军事资助的决定。当然，这会对我们继续战斗的能力产生巨大影响。哦，等一下，等一下。让我……如果你们能听到的话。
[ALARM BLARING]
[警报声响起]
So there is an air alert going on, if you can hear the signal.
所以现在有空袭警报，如果你们能听到信号的话。
Whoa. Yeah. What does that mean?
哇。是的。那意味着什么？
It kind of sounds like those-- there might be some air attack, like drones, or a missile, or something like this.
听起来像是……可能会有空袭，比如无人机，或者导弹，或者类似这样的东西。
Do you have to go hide somewhere, or what do you do?
你必须去哪里躲起来，还是做什么？
No, I'll go brew myself a cup of tea maybe.
不，我可能会去给自己泡杯茶。
That's how long this war has been going on, long enough that there's an air attack, and you go brew yourself a cup of tea. When Donald Trump won the election, Serhei was sitting in a dugout on the front line. That's basically just a big square hole in the ground, 100 square feet, like in World War I, five guys all huddled together.
这场战争已经进行了这么久了，久到有空袭，你却去给自己泡杯茶。当唐纳德·特朗普赢得大选时，谢尔盖正坐在前线的掩体里。那基本上只是地上的一个大方洞，100 平方英尺，就像一战时那样，五个人挤在一起。
That night, they'd just finished firing at the Russians, sat down to rest, when one of the guys in his unit went on X, saw the news that Trump was winning, and read it aloud.
那天晚上，他们刚停止向俄国人开火，坐下来休息，这时他部队里的一个人上了 X，看到了特朗普获胜的新闻，并大声读了出来。
He went all like, oh, this guy wins. And if he wins, he will end all the help to Ukraine, and we are basically screwed. We went into full discussion of how the American democracy works, like bringing up Wikipedia pages. We spent around three hours of our night time just by talking, talking, talking about what the president in America has the power to do.
他就像，哦，这个家伙赢了。如果他赢了，他将结束对乌克兰的所有援助，我们就基本完蛋了。我们进入了关于美国民主如何运作的全面讨论，比如拿出维基百科页面。我们花了大约三个小时的夜晚时间只是在谈论、谈论、谈论美国总统有权做什么。
Could Trump just stop the war unilaterally? Stop sending aid they'd already promised? And what's the deal with the House and the Senate? Did he need their permission? Serhei and the other soldiers dug and dug for answers.
特朗普能单方面结束战争吗？停止发送他们已经承诺的援助？众议院和参议院是怎么回事？他需要他们的许可吗？谢尔盖和其他士兵挖呀挖，寻找答案。
And here's where he came down. He concluded that Trump wouldn't have the power to reverse the aid Biden had already promised all at once-- which isn't exactly true, but that's what he told his unit.
这就是他的结论。他得出结论，特朗普没有权力一次性推翻拜登已经承诺的援助——虽然这并不完全正确，但这正是他告诉他部队的话。
Did you feel like it was your job to calm everyone down?
你觉得安抚大家是你的工作吗？
Maybe calming in a way that I don't want my crew member to fill their heads with downgraded morale for the next five days. We need to be going hand in hand for our mission.
也许是以这种方式安抚，我不希望我的队员在接下来的五天里脑子里充满士气低落的想法。我们需要为了我们的使命携手并进。
These kinds of conversations have been happening on the Ukrainian front line for months now. Not all the time, but here and there. I talked to 10 people in a variety of positions on the front. They all laughed when I asked about Trump saying he could finish the war in 24 hours.
这类谈话在乌克兰前线已经持续几个月了。不是一直，但时有发生。我和前线各种职位的 10 个人谈过。当我问起特朗普说他能在 24 小时内结束战争时，他们都笑了。
Of course, they remembered the first time he said it. They remembered where they were, what they were doing. But they didn't think much of it, except for the fact that Trump was a showman and that this was all part of his act.
当然，他们记得他第一次说这话时。他们记得他们在哪里，在做什么。但他们没怎么把它当回事，除了特朗普是个表演者，这一切都是他表演的一部分。
But even so, that didn't stop them from wondering-- what in the world might he mean? Same thing happened a few days after Trump won the election in November. Joe Biden approved Ukraine's use of long-range missiles. The soldiers were excited. They'd been waiting for this for years.
但即便如此，这也没能阻止他们思考——他到底是什么意思？特朗普在 11 月赢得大选几天后，同样的事情发生了。乔·拜登批准了乌克兰使用远程导弹。士兵们很兴奋。他们为此等了几年。
But then Donald Trump said that he thought launching long-range missiles into Russia was actually a big mistake. One soldier told me that he was on the front line, just finished shooting mortars when he heard what Trump had said. And he looked at his crew like, what? What does this actually mean for us? Will they actually take away the approval they've just given us?
但随后唐纳德·特朗普说，他认为向俄罗斯发射远程导弹实际上是个大错误。一名士兵告诉我，他当时在前线，刚打完迫击炮，听到特朗普说的话。他看着他的队员们，仿佛在说，什么？这对我们到底意味着什么？他们真的会收回刚刚给我们的批准吗？
Another soldier who told me about trying to read the tea leaves of American politics is Vitaly, a drone operator. He's from a region of Ukraine that's been in the fight against Russian occupation since 2014. Vitaly has been fighting this war on and off since he was 24.
另一名告诉我试图解读美国政治茶叶的士兵是维塔利，一名无人机操作员。他来自乌克兰的一个地区，该地区自 2014 年以来一直处于对抗俄罗斯占领的战斗中。维塔利从 24 岁起就断断续续地在打这场战争。
As a drone operator, he spends hours sitting in a bunker watching monitors. He's got two screens in front of him. On one is a live feed surveillance of the front line and the other, his phone-- social media, group chats, the news-- one right next to the other.
作为一名无人机操作员，他花几个小时坐在地堡里盯着监视器。他面前有两个屏幕。一个是前线的实时监控视频，另一个是他的手机——社交媒体、群聊、新闻——一个接一个地并排着。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
Oftentimes, we talk in the evenings while looking at the monitors because there's not much action during the night. The Russians usually start moving early in the morning before the sunrise. These conversations are meant to pass the time, because now it's winter, and the night is long. And you have a lot of time to kill, in fact. Because war is not always action. War is very often sitting put for a long time.
通常，我们在晚上看着监视器时会聊天，因为晚上没什么行动。俄国人通常在日出前清晨开始行动。这些谈话是为了打发时间，因为现在是冬天，夜晚很长。事实上，你有大把的时间需要消磨。因为战争并不总是行动。战争很多时候是长时间原地不动。
They talk about how Trump, the candidate, could be against funding for Ukraine. But Trump, the president, might not be.
他们谈论候选人特朗普怎么可能反对资助乌克兰。但总统特朗普可能不会。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
Sometimes, we'll just be sitting there in our positions in the basements, and someone will say that Trump doesn't actually care about any of this, or us, and that he will make a deal with Russia at whatever price is most favorable to him.
有时，我们只是坐在地下室的位置上，有人会说特朗普实际上并不关心这一切，或者我们，他会以对他最有利的价格与俄罗斯达成协议。
Then, there's the people who will say that Trump actually understands everything and will try to talk to Putin. And Putin will not want to come to an agreement and will not want to give us any territories. And so Trump will realize that there can be no agreement with Putin and will instead provide us with lots of new weapons, thanks to which we can win.
然后，还有人会说特朗普实际上明白这一切，并会试图与普京交谈。普京将不想达成任何协议，也不会想给我们任何领土。所以特朗普会意识到与普京无法达成协议，反而会给我们提供大量新武器，多亏了这些，我们才能赢。
Vitaly told me he actually finds this last scenario pretty convincing. Other times, he's less optimistic.
维塔利告诉我，他其实觉得这最后一个剧本很有说服力。其他时候，他没那么乐观。
One day, I was sitting looking at the monitor, my phone next to it, just scrolling, and there was Trump's tweet. And then I turn, and I tell my fellow servicemen, hey, take a look. There's Musk, who's considered a visionary. But Musk writes such offensive things about Ukraine.
有一天，我坐着看着监视器，旁边放着手机，只是在滑动，看到了特朗普的推文。然后我转过头告诉我的战友，嘿，看一眼。那是马斯克，被认为是有远见的人。但马斯克写了这么多关于乌克兰的侮辱性内容。
Elon Musk has said there's no way that Putin will lose. And he pitched a Ukraine, quote unquote, "peace plan" on X, which would cede Crimea to Russia.
埃隆·马斯克说，普京不可能输。他在 X 上提出了一个乌克兰，引用引号，“和平计划”，这将把克里米亚割让给俄罗斯。
And, now, he's going to be sitting in Trump's administration. And we were all like, shit. Maybe he'll change? Maybe he'll be different as a politician when he gets some experience. One of the guys in the unit said, my brother has a Tesla. If I had known this guy would be a part of this, I would have convinced him not to buy it.
而且，现在，他将坐在特朗普的政府中。我们都觉得，糟了。也许他会变？也许当他获得一些经验时，作为政治家他会不同。部队里的一个人说，我兄弟有一辆特斯拉。如果我知道这家伙会是其中的一部分，我会说服他不买的。
Trump's victory has cracked open a space for conversations that were once totally off-limits. I heard about a moment like that from Artem, a soldier with a big personality. Artem is a volunteer fighter in a unit that calls themselves Peaky Blinders. He helps prepare ammunition for drones. He calls himself the Candy Maker.
特朗普的胜利开启了一个曾经完全被禁止的谈话空间。我从阿尔乔姆那里听到了这样一个时刻，一个个性鲜明的士兵。阿尔乔姆是“剃刀党”部队的一名志愿战士。他帮助为无人机准备弹药。他自称是“糖果制造者”。
Artem is a big believer that the war is nowhere near ending, Trump or no Trump, funding or no funding. But a few weeks ago, Artem went out with his commander, Zalizniak, and another guy in his unit.
阿尔乔姆坚信这场战争远未结束，不管特朗普与否，不管资助与否。但几周前，阿尔乔姆和他的指挥官扎利兹尼亚克以及部队里的另一个人出去了。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
In the evening, we went out to a hookah lounge and sat down to relax with our brothers in arms. We were sitting at the table, together with Chyzh and Zalizniak in this cafe, where we ordered ourselves some dinner. And the guys ordered a hookah as well. I don't smoke hookah, but they do.
晚上，我们去了一家水烟休息室，和我们的战友们坐下来放松。我们坐在桌旁，和奇日与扎利兹尼亚克一起在这家咖啡馆，我们点了晚餐。小伙子们还点了一壶水烟。我不抽水烟，但他们抽。
That was when our conversation began. When the waiter took our order, Zalizniak looked up, deep in thought. He then turned his eyes to Chyzh and began to ask him some questions.
那就是我们谈话开始的时候。当服务员接单时，扎利兹尼亚克抬头，陷入深思。然后他把目光转向奇日，开始问他一些问题。
Chyzh is a soldier in Artem's unit.
奇日是阿尔乔姆部队的一名士兵。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
He asked, Chyzh, if the war ends, what would you do? He asked what he thought his future would look like after the war was over. They started to speculate what events would unfold, who would travel, who would do what, basically pouring out their hearts to one another.
他问，奇日，如果战争结束，你会做什么？他问他认为战争结束后他的未来会是什么样子。他们开始推测会发生什么事件，谁会去旅行，谁会做什么，基本上是在向对方倾诉心声。
Artem couldn't believe that he was hearing his fellow brothers in arms talking about what they would do after the war ended-- going to travel, going back to their normal civilian lives.
阿尔乔姆简直不敢相信他听到战友们在谈论战争结束后他们会做什么——去旅行，回到他们正常的平民生活中。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语语音]
I told him I didn't believe it.
我告诉他我不相信。
To hear a fellow soldier even whisper the possibility that the fight could be over is still not something Artem is used to. The party line of any Ukrainian soldier, of any Ukrainian, really, is that they'll fight to the end, and the fight may never end. Expressing any sort of doubt feels almost unpatriotic.
听到战友甚至低声说出战斗可能结束的可能性，仍然不是阿尔乔姆习惯的事情。任何乌克兰士兵，任何乌克兰人的官方立场，其实是他们会战斗到底，而战斗可能永远不会结束。表达任何怀疑感觉几乎是不爱国。
But I talked to a Ukrainian expert who's in contact with many high-ranking officials in the army, who told me that while many soldiers remain diehard and committed to keep fighting till the end, another group, which is growing, is made up of people who are getting increasingly weary of this war. Ukraine's recently suffered a series of setbacks and defeats, and the expert says, this group likes that Trump is someone who will change things up.
但我采访了一位与军方许多高级官员有联系的乌克兰专家，他告诉我，虽然许多士兵仍然顽强并致力于战斗到底，但另一个群体正在增长，由那些对这场战争越来越感到厌倦的人组成。乌克兰最近遭受了一系列挫折和失败，专家说，这个群体喜欢特朗普，因为他是一个会改变局面的人。
Artem thought about this moment with his commander for a while. What had he meant by that? Did he actually think this war would end? Artem told me this. A few days later, in the midst of heavy bombardment, he studied his commanders face. He looked like he was all in. And so Artem decided that his commander didn't mean what he said. He told me he'd figured it out. His commander didn't actually think the war was ending. He was just testing his unit.
阿尔乔姆想了很久那个和指挥官的时刻。他那是什么意思？他真的认为这场战争会结束吗？阿尔乔姆告诉我这个。几天后，在猛烈的轰炸中，他研究了他指挥官的脸。他看起来像是在全力以赴。所以阿尔乔姆决定他指挥官并没有说出他想说的话。他告诉我他想通了。他的指挥官并不真的认为战争要结束了。他只是在测试他的部队。
The truth is, these guys don't think about Trump all that much. They've got other things on their minds. One soldier told me that when you're in the rear, far from the front line, it's easy to imagine all the possibilities of what could happen next.
事实是，这些人并不怎么考虑特朗普。他们有别的事情要担心。一名士兵告诉我，当你身处后方，远离前线时，很容易想象接下来可能发生的所有可能性。
But when you're on the front, it's like all of that collapses into this one linear logic-- the weapon in front of you, the tank next to you, the amount of ammo you have left-- the present, no before and no after. Those are the moments, he said, that feel the greatest for him, when he just does what he can with what he has, when he's not speculating about what will be.
但当你身处前线时，这一切都坍缩成这种线性逻辑——你面前的武器，你旁边的坦克，你剩下的弹药量——现在，没有之前，也没有之后。他说，那是他感觉最棒的时刻，当他用他所拥有的做他能做的，当他不推测未来会怎样时。
Valerie Kipnis is a producer on our show. She reported this with help from Anastastassiia Mozhghova. Coming up, the power of a simple photograph in a moment of uncertainty. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
瓦莱丽·基普尼斯是我们节目的制片人。她与阿纳斯塔西亚·莫日戈娃一起报道了此事。接下来，一张简单照片在不确定时刻的力量。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today, on our program, Pivot Point. On this weekend, before a new presidency begins, we have stories of people living in these strange and often unsettling in-between moment, when you know things are right on the cusp of big, big changes. We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, Period Piece.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，在我们的节目中，转折点。在这个新总统就职前的周末，我们有关于人们生活在这些奇怪且通常令人不安的中间时刻的故事，当你知道事情正处于重大变化的边缘时。我们已经到达节目的第三幕。第三幕，时期作品。
So when we were discussing this week's theme as a group here at the radio show, one of our co-workers, Susan Burton, started talking about a year-long pivot point. It lasts 12 months that many of our listeners have either gone through, or are in the middle of now, or will go through. Quick heads up-- Susan describes some bodily stuff in here. Here she is.
所以当我们在这里广播节目的小组讨论本周主题时，我们的一位同事苏珊·伯顿开始谈论一个为期一年的转折点。它持续 12 个月，我们许多听众要么经历过，要么正处于其中，要么将要经历。快速提醒一下——苏珊在里面描述了一些身体上的事情。她在这里。
I got my first period when I was 10, and then I continued to get it for the next 40 years. I didn't get it every month. There were exceptions, blackout dates-- pregnancy, breastfeeding, anorexia. But for most of the 40 years, each month, my period would come, and I'd open a calendar and mark the anticipated date of my next period with a TK, like a forthcoming fact in a piece I was reporting.
我 10 岁时来了第一次月经，然后接下来的 40 年里一直都有。我不是每个月都来。有例外，停经日期——怀孕、母乳喂养、厌食症。但在 40 年的大部分时间里，每个月，我的月经都会来，我会打开日历，在预计下次月经的日期上做一个标记，就像我在报道的一篇文章中标记即将来临的事实。
Sometimes, I would get my period and not have tampons, and then I would go online and order enough tampons so that I would never run out again. And then suddenly, I was about to turn 50, and I understood I would never get through all the tampons I had ordered.
有时，我月经来了却没有卫生棉条，然后我会上网订购足够的卫生棉条，这样我就永远不会再用完了。然后突然之间，我就要 50 岁了，我明白我永远也用不完我订购的所有卫生棉条。
What was the first day of your last period? Asked the nurse at the gynecologist's office. OK, I said. I mean, I think it was sometime last month, like August, but it's hard to tell. I'm at that age, you know? Like, I was kind of bleeding all summer. Not in an alarming way, just, it was hard to tell.
你最后一次月经的第一天是什么时候？妇科医生诊室的护士问道。好的，我说。我是说，我想是上个月的某个时候，比如八月，但很难说。我到了那个年龄，你知道吗？就像，我整个夏天都在出血。不是那种令人担忧的方式，只是，很难分辨。
You are officially in menopause once you go one full year without a period. So I was not there yet. I was in perimenopause. During peri, my period had first come a lot, every 18 days. Over time, that changed-- 60 days between periods, then 90. I'd start thinking, this is it, and then I'd get my period again, and the clock would restart. Congratulations, a friend said to me one day when the counter reset to zero. She was kidding, but that was the feeling.
一旦你一年没有月经，你就在医学上正式进入更年期了。所以我还没到那一步。我处于围绝经期。在围绝经期期间，我的月经起初来得很频繁，每 18 天一次。随着时间推移，那改变了——两次月经之间间隔 60 天，然后 90 天。我开始想，就是这样了，然后我又来了月经，时钟又重新开始了。当你把计数器重置为零时，一位朋友有一天向我祝贺。她是在开玩笑，但那就是那种感觉。
Peri was a safe zone, and I wanted to stay there. What made peri a safe zone was simply that it was not menopause. It was still the before time. Peri may have been a safe zone, but it was not a safe harbor.
围绝经期是一个安全区，我想留在那儿。让围绝经期成为安全区的原因很简单，那就是它不是绝经。那仍然是“之前”的时间。围绝经期可能是一个安全区，但它不是一个安全港。
During it, I had the common symptoms you hear about and other things you don't-- frozen shoulder, which was just what it sounded like, migraines I managed by digging my fingernails into my forehead. There were remedies for some of the symptoms, but what I tried or didn't is not what I want to get into here.
在此期间，我有你听说过的常见症状和其他你没听说过的——冻结肩，听起来就是那么回事，我通过将指甲深陷额头来控制偏头痛。有些症状有补救办法，但我尝试过或没尝试过什么并不是我这里想讨论的。
My point is that I had already been through a few rocky years, years of accelerated aging. I felt startled by how quickly my face was changing. According to the internet, this was on me. There was a punitive quality to the phrase "sun damage."
我想说的是，我已经经历了几年糟糕的时光，几年加速衰老的岁月。我对自己脸部变化的如此之快感到吃惊。根据互联网的说法，这是我自找的。这种说法有一种惩罚性的质感。
But the promise was that once you were officially in menopause, you would feel better because things would slow down, and your moods would level out. You would come into your own. You would give a shit less. In menopause, you would be sanguine. And yet, I wasn't eager to get there.
但承诺是，一旦你正式进入更年期，你会感觉更好，因为事情会慢下来，你的情绪会趋于平稳。你会活出自我。你会少在乎一些狗屁事。在更年期，你会保持乐观。然而，我并不急于达到那个状态。
All along, I had so many fears about menopause. A short list of those fears might start with my associations to the word-- dry, wiry, papery. I was scared of what would happen to desire, like how much of it I would feel. The messaging on this was positive. Women in menopause can still be sexy and still want sex.
一直以来，我对更年期有很多恐惧。这些恐惧的短名单可能会从我对这个词的联想开始——干、枯、薄如纸。我害怕欲望会发生什么，比如我会感受到多少。这方面的信息是积极的。更年期的女性仍然可以性感，仍然想要性。
But the celebrities of menopause were hot and liberated, and you hardly heard from the regular women, who maybe did want less. And that was the information I was looking for, how it felt to still be sexual, but to have the volume just turned down a bit, because that was what I suspected was most true. I didn't know yet. I wasn't there. But I thought I might be closer than I'd ever been.
但更年期的名人都是火辣且解放的，而你几乎听不到普通女性的声音，她们可能欲望确实减少了。而那正是我想寻找的信息，作为性存在但音量调低一点是什么感觉，因为我觉得那才是最真实的。我还不知道。我还没到那一步。但我认为我可能比以往任何时候都更接近了。
That period I'd had in August-- light, persistent-- I had a feeling it would be the last one. My bet was that once the hand on the clock circled through the year, that would be it. I would officially be in menopause. September, October, November, December-- no period. Still in the before time.
八月的那次月经——轻微、持久——我有一种预感这将是最后一次。我打赌，当时钟指针转过一年，就结束了。我会正式进入更年期。九月、十月、十一月、十二月——没有月经。仍然在“之前”的时间里。
It was sort of like not wanting to move into a new decade, like wanting to linger in the last months of being 29, 39, 49, or 9. Even as a child, I'd had a sadness about aging, not wanting to cross into the double digits of 10. Getting a period at 10 was early, very early, in 1984. I'd felt horror at that advancement. Now, I recognize that this was happening again.
这有点像不想进入一个新的十年，就像想在 29、39、49 或 9 岁的最后几个月里徘徊。即使作为一个孩子，我对衰老也有一种悲伤，不想跨入 10 岁的两位数。在 1984 年，10 岁来月经是很早的，非常早。我当时对那种进步感到恐惧。现在，我意识到这又发生了。
As the year ticked on-- now January, now February-- I found there were things I missed about menstruating. There was a stillness in my body without it. I missed the cycle, which began each month with a low, flat mood, and then continued with the rising action of ovulation, that mid-month surge of energy, some of it erotic. I missed the elevation in mood.
随着这一年过去——现在是一月，现在是二月——我发现有些关于行经的事情我怀念了。没有它，我的身体有一种宁静。我怀念那个周期，每个月从低沉、平淡的情绪开始，然后继续随着排卵的上升动作，月中那阵能量的激增，其中一些是色情的。我怀念情绪的高涨。
March. Earlier in my life, fearing pregnancy, I'd willed my period to come, but it wasn't like that now. I wasn't pulling down my underwear and hoping. April, May. I was still in the before time, though I was increasingly accepting of the idea that I would soon be in menopause, testing it out in my head.
三月。在生命的早期，担心怀孕时，我曾希望月经来，但现在不是那样了。我没有拉下内衣然后期盼。四月、五月。我仍然在“之前”的时间里，尽管我越来越接受我很快就会进入更年期这个想法，并在脑海中预演着。
Maybe this is partly because a whole new generation, Millennials, had discovered perimenopause and, once again, were shining up the scruffy territory we Gen Xers had claimed. Advertisers had gotten there, too. And now it seemed like everyone was talking about menopause. But most of them were not talking about it the right way. And this is probably always true. No one is ever talking about your own menopause, about exactly what it means to you.
也许这部分是因为整整一代人，千禧一代，发现了围绝经期，并再次照亮了我们 X 世代所宣称的那片粗犷领地。广告商也到了那里。现在似乎每个人都在谈论更年期。但他们大多数谈论的方式并不对。而这可能永远是真实的。没有人会谈论你自己的更年期，关于它对你到底意味着什么。
June, month 10. By now, I was traveling without any supplies. There wasn't going to be an emergency. There wasn't going to be another period stain. For years, I dealt with period stains, kneeling by the washing machine, spraying stain remover into a seam, or looking at the back of a skirt and wondering if it could be saved.
六月，第 10 个月。到现在，我旅行时不带任何补给。不会有紧急情况了。不会再有另一次经期污渍。多年来，我处理过经期污渍，跪在洗衣机旁，把去污剂喷进缝隙里，或者看着裙子背面想知道它是否还能抢救。
But there's one stain I've never been able to get out, a stain on the pink upholstery of one of our dining room chairs. I sat there one early summer morning, for me, a singularly important morning. A book I'd written had been published. I sat there in a nightgown, reading a glowing review. I could feel that I was getting my period, but it didn't matter. A dream of my life was coming true. I wanted to sit there in it. I didn't want to move.
但有一个污渍我从来没能弄掉，那是我们餐厅椅子之一粉色软垫上的污渍。那是一个夏初的早晨，对我来说，一个极其重要的早晨，我坐在那里。我写的一本书出版了。我穿着睡袍坐在那里，读着一篇精彩的评论。我能感觉到我的月经来了，但那并不重要。我生命中的一个梦想成真了。我想坐在那里沉浸其中。我不想动。
Now that stain is there, and I've tried to lift it, but it won't come out. And I don't mind that it's there. It's a marker of a moment of bliss and of an earlier self, too, one whose body still did that. For so many years, I tried to manage my period, make it invisible, get rid of evidence. Now, this strange, possibly even repulsive, kind of preservation. But it's a stain that makes me remember the feeling of the world opening up before me.
现在那个污渍还在那儿，我试过把它弄掉，但弄不掉。我不介意它在那儿。它是幸福时刻的标记，也是一个早期自我的标记，身体还在做那个动作的那个自我。多年来，我试图处理我的月经，让它隐形，去掉证据。现在，这种奇怪，甚至可能令人反感的保护。但这是一种让我记住世界在我面前展开的感觉的污渍。
July came, and then it was August again. And it was official, one full year. Is it too pollyanna to say that I actually did feel the world opening up? There had been something trying about wanting to stay where I was. Once I crossed the threshold, there was no more resistance. And I was moving forward again.
七月来了，然后又是一年八月。正式满一年了。说我真的感觉世界在展开，这太盲目乐观了吗？一直想留在原地是件很费劲的事。一旦我跨过门槛，就没有了阻力。而我又在前进。
When I went for my physical, my doctor said, what was the date of your last menstrual period? August 2023, I said. Menopause, she said, with an exclamation point, like Menopause, the musical, like a curtain rising on a new stage.
当我去做体检时，我的医生说，你最后一次月经的日期是什么时候？2023 年 8 月，我说。更年期，她说，带着感叹号，就像《更年期音乐剧》一样，就像帷幕在一个新舞台上拉开。
Susan Burton is an editor on our show.
苏珊·伯顿是我们节目的编辑。
Act Four, Since You've Been Gone. So the show today is about people at a pivot point, and one entire community in that situation is Altadena, California. It's one of the towns around LA that's so devastated that, for most of the last week and a half, nobody was allowed in. It's been surrounded by National Guard with barricades.
第四幕，自从你走后。所以今天的节目是关于处在转折点的人们，而在这个情况下的整个社区是加利福尼亚州的阿尔塔迪纳。它是洛杉矶周围受灾严重的城镇之一，以至于在过去一周半的大部分时间里，没人被允许进入。它一直被国民警卫队用路障包围着。
One of our producers, Miki Meek, talked to somebody who stayed at her house-- the fire stopped about a block away-- and, in the first days of the fires, came up with a mission for herself.
我们的制片人之一，米基·米克，和一位住在她家的人谈过——火灾在大约一个街区外停止了——并且，在火灾的最初几天里，她为自己想出了一个使命。
Vanessa Prata is a nursing student, 25 years old, lives with her parents in the home she grew up in. In those first few days after the fires, she realized people who'd evacuated didn't have a way to figure out if their homes were still standing or not.
瓦妮莎·普拉塔是一名护理系学生，25 岁，和父母住在她从小长大的家里。在火灾后的最初几天里，她意识到那些撤离的人无法知道他们的家是否还在。
And I remember, I was just sitting and thinking, like, well, one thing we've been doing is driving around. So maybe something I can do to help is drive around and take pictures of these homes.
我记得，我当时只是坐着想，好吧，我们一直在做的一件事就是开车四处转。所以也许我能做的一件有帮助的事就是开车四处转，给这些房子拍照。
So she went on to a community Facebook page for Altadena and posted this message.
所以她去了阿尔塔迪纳的一个社区 Facebook 页面，发布了这个消息。
So I said, "Hello, everyone. Our home and family is all OK and safe. That being said, we are behind the barricades. We are more than happy to drive around and take a picture for any person who would like to see their home or, God forbid, what is left of their home. Please let me know the address."
所以我说，“大家好。我们的家和家人都很安全。话虽如此，我们被挡在了路障后面。如果有谁想看他们的家，或者天哪，看看家里还剩下什么，我们非常乐意开车四处转，拍张照片。请告诉我地址。”
And then how fast did you start getting responses?
然后你多快开始得到回复？
So I started getting responses pretty quickly, probably, like, 5, 10 minutes after I posted it. And then when they shared the address, they write something, and they say, oh, I brought my children home to that house. I've had people say, I was born in that house, actually. I had somebody say, my grandma was born in the house. I was married in that house.
所以我很快就开始得到回复，大概是在我发布后 5、10 分钟。然后当他们分享地址时，他们会写一些东西，他们说，哦，我把我的孩子们带回家到那栋房子。有些人说，我实际上就是在那个房子里出生的。有人说，我奶奶是在那房子出生的。我在那个房子里结婚的。
54 people messaged her their addresses. She wrote them down into a notebook, and then she and her dad got into their old Toyota minivan and started driving.
54 个人给她发了他们的地址。她把它们记进笔记本，然后她和她爸爸上了他们那辆旧丰田面包车，开始开车。
See, Papa? That Prius melted.
看，爸爸？那辆普锐斯融化了。
Vanessa in the passenger seat and her father driving.
瓦妮莎坐在副驾驶座位上，她父亲开车。
OK, that one is on the left side, just a few.
好的，那一个在左侧，只有几个。
[DOG PANTING]
[狗喘气声]
That's their dog, Shelby, panting on her father's lap.
那是他们的狗，谢尔比，在她父亲的膝盖上喘气。
Look, it's here somewhere. Where? On the right side.
看，它就在这儿附近。在哪？在右侧。
I think it's this. They mentioned this part.
我想是这个。他们提到了这个部分。
No, it's this one.
不，是这一个。
They got to 10 houses on their first day, but it took them almost four hours. Altadena is a small place. The whole thing is only about 9 square miles. But the streets were blocked with downed power lines and fallen trees. When they did get to an address, Vanessa would snap a photo and text it right away.
他们第一天到了 10 户人家，但这花了他们将近四个小时。阿尔塔迪纳是个小地方。整个地方只有约 9 平方英里。但街道被倒下的电线和树木堵住了。当他们到达地址时，瓦妮莎会拍张照片并立即发送短信。
The goal is to get the photos as quick as possible, without delay, to these people about their homes, because you can imagine the agony of somebody sitting in a shelter not knowing.
目标是尽快地，毫无延迟地将照片送到这些关于他们家的人手中，因为你可以想象一个人坐在收容所里不知道的痛苦。
So how many people have you responded to so far?
所以你到现在回复了多少人？
We've done about 41, and I think we have another seven or eight today.
我们完成了大约 41 个，我想我们今天还有七八个。
And then of those 41 that you've been able to check on, how many are still standing?
然后在那 41 个你能检查的房子里，有多少还站着？
Less than half.
不到一半。
Less than half. OK.
不到一半。好的。
Yeah. Less than half.
是的。不到一半。
Can you just explain the process to me of--
你能给我解释一下这个过程……
It's difficult. So when the house is there, I send the picture, and I don't say anything because there is no words needed. Usually, I get a "thank you." When the house isn't there, that's when it becomes a little bit more challenging. Some people will send me, hey, can you send me the status of my home? I know it's probably gone, but it would be great to know what the situation looks like."
这很难。所以当房子还在时，我发照片，我什么都不说，因为不需要任何言语。通常，我会得到一个“谢谢”。当房子不在时，这就变得有点挑战性了。有些人会发给我，嘿，你能发给我房子的状态吗？我知道它可能没了，但知道情况是什么样的会很好。”
And then there's the ones that are like, I have no idea. If you could send me a picture. And those are the hard ones because you know you're the one who's going to break the news. And so I send a picture, and I say, I'm so sorry for your loss. It's usually all I say. And they usually respond with something. And then I'll follow up with, I wish I could do more to help. Like, I wish there was something else I could do to help, you know? There's not much you can say if somebody's lost their home.
然后还有那些说，我完全不知道。如果你能给我发张照片。那些是很难的，因为你知道你就是那个要打破这个消息的人。所以我发张照片，然后说，我为你失去家园感到非常抱歉。通常这就是我说的全部。他们通常会回复一些东西。然后我会跟进说，我希望我能做更多来帮助。就像，我希望还有别的事情我可以做来帮助，你知道吗？如果有人失去了房子，没太多你能说的。
And then I've also had the occasional, after I send the burnt house, they'll send me photos of the house prior. I remember one of the houses that they sent that burned, oh, my god, it was really burnt. And they sent me a picture. The house was beautiful. I mean, it really was. That one was hard.
然后我也偶尔会遇到这种情况，在我发了烧毁的房子后，他们会发给我之前的房子照片。我记得其中一个烧毁的房子，天哪，它烧得很厉害。他们发给我照片。这房子很漂亮。我是说，它真的很好。那一个很难受。
Yeah. How did you respond back?
是的。你是怎么回信的？
What a beautiful home. I'm so sorry. I mean, it really was. It had a beautiful garden. I'm looking at the picture now. It's a dark brown roof. The house is off-white. And the yard has bushes. And the bushes have small pink flowers. They had a bench on the outside of their house. And it's a red bench, which really goes with the house, honestly, because it really complemented the color of the house. It made it stick out, you know?
多漂亮的家啊。我非常抱歉。我是说，它真的很好。它有一个美丽的花园。我正在看照片。是一个深棕色的屋顶。房子是灰白色的。院子里有灌木丛。灌木丛上有小粉花。他们房子的外面有一条长椅。那是一条红色的长椅，说实话，真的和房子很搭，因为它真的衬托了房子的颜色。它让它很突出，你知道吗？
A few days after the fire started, when it was still only 3% contained, she and her father were trying to get to an address at the end of a cul-de-sac. That one house took them a couple days to get to. They kept trying different roads in.
火灾开始几天后，当它仅被控制了 3% 时，她和父亲正试图到达死胡同尽头的一个地址。那个房子他们花了几天时间才到达。他们一直尝试不同的路进入。
Every way had a tree, a huge tree, that fell in the middle of the road, blocking it. And I said, this is going to be the one that I'm not going to be able to send a picture for. And I was just-- you know. And I saw the person. She had a family. And I was like, oh, my god. I'm telling my dad, we need to see what we can do. We need to try, you know?
每一条路都有一棵树，一棵大树，倒在路中间，挡住了路。我说，这将是我无法发送照片的那一个。我只是……你知道。我看到了那个人。她有个家庭。我当时想，天哪。我在告诉爸爸，我们需要看看我们能做什么。我们需要尝试，你知道吗？
On their fourth attempt, they finally got closer to the address, but encountered another tree blocking the road. So Vanessa got out of the car and started walking. She sent me the video.
在第四次尝试时，他们终于靠近了地址，但遇到了另一棵树挡路。所以瓦妮莎下了车，开始走路。她发给我视频。
OK, OK.
好的，好的。
Around her were charred trees and electrical poles dangling from power lines. The bottoms burn completely off.
她周围是烧焦的树木和悬挂在电线上的电线杆。底部完全烧掉了。
I'm walking under the poles and going in between wires. I couldn't figure out which house it was. I mean, that area was demolished. It looks like somebody dropped a bomb in that area. And there's nothing. You know when you go to a house, and you see those house numbers on the curb?
我走在电线杆下，穿过电线。我认不出是哪栋房子。我是说，那个区域被夷为平地了。看起来就像有人在那儿投下了一枚炸弹。什么都没有。你知道当你去一栋房子时，你会看到路缘石上的门牌号吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯嗯。
It was so bad that those house numbers were nonexistent.
严重到那些门牌号都不存在了。
The rubble was still smoldering, and all she could see were remnants of stone walls and chimney columns, a burned out station wagon.
瓦砾仍在冒烟，她能看到的只有石墙和烟囱柱的残骸，一辆烧毁的旅行车。
But it was just like, I'm going to make a general video and just hopefully I hit the house. And I sent that one, and I told the person, please let me know if I am getting your house because I'm here now, and I can get another picture or get another video if needed. And they said, no, that's perfect. You got it.
但这就像，我要拍个通用视频，希望我能拍到房子。我发了那个视频，我告诉那个人，请让我知道我是否拍到了你的房子，因为我现在就在这儿，如果需要我可以再拍一张照片或拍个视频。他们说，不，那很完美。你拍到了。
One of the last messages I got from Vanessa was a rare bright moment in this terrible time.
我从瓦妮莎那里收到的最后几条消息之一是在这个可怕时间里罕见的明亮时刻。
Oh, my god! [LAUGHS] So take a picture here and walk there, and take the other one.
天哪！[笑] 所以在这里拍张照，走到那儿，再拍另一张。
She and her dad found a house still standing.
她和她爸爸发现了一栋还站着的房子。
Wonderful, right?
很棒，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
But go through that gate.
但穿过那个大门。
Miki Meek is a producer on our show.
米基·米克是我们节目的制片人。
Well, our program was produced today by Emanuel Dzotsi. The people who put together today's show include Phia Bennin, Dana Chivvis, Michael Comite, Angela Gervasi, Cassie Howley, Chana Joffe-Walt, Henry Larson, Seth Lind, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Laura Starcheski, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, and Diane Wu.
好吧，我们今天的节目由伊曼纽尔·佐齐制作。参与制作今天节目的包括菲亚·贝宁、达纳·奇维斯、迈克尔·科米特、安吉拉·格瓦西、卡西·豪利、查纳·乔夫-沃尔特、亨利·拉尔森、塞斯·林德、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、阿丽莎·希普、劳拉·斯塔切斯基、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、玛丽莎·罗伯逊-泰克斯特和黛安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Tasia Plieshyvtseva, Eric Ciaramella, Katerina Sergatskova, Michael O'Hanlon, John Litchfield, Bennett Epstein, Vanessa Martinez, Ron Lin, Jeanette Marantos, and Hannah Fry at the LA Times. The actors performing the English translations for the Ukrainians in Act 2 of our show today were Oleksander Fuhrman and Ross Peleh.
我们的执行编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里。今天特别感谢塔西亚·普利希夫采娃、埃里克·恰拉梅拉、卡特琳娜·谢尔加茨科娃、迈克尔·奥汉隆、约翰·利奇菲尔德、本内特·爱泼斯坦、瓦妮莎·马丁内斯、罗恩·林、珍妮特·马兰托斯以及《洛杉矶时报》的汉娜·弗莱。今天为我们节目第二幕中的乌克兰人进行英语翻译表演的演员是奥列克桑德尔·富尔曼和罗斯·佩勒。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. To become a This American Life partner, which gets you bonus content, ad-free listening, and hundreds of our favorite episodes of the show that are going to show up right in your podcast feed, go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. Your subscription also helps keep our program going.
《美国生活》由 PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。要成为《美国生活》的合作伙伴，这将为您带来额外内容、无广告收听以及我们数百集最受欢迎的节目，这些节目将直接显示在您的播客源中，请前往 thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。您的订阅也有助于维持我们的节目进行。
Thanks this week to Life Partner Cici Chen Mengfei and Colette Spriggins. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He's been taking a figure drawing class. His drawings are pretty good, except for the hands. He does the shoulder, upper arm, forearm all great. And then gets to the end of the arm, and it's always--
感谢本周的合作伙伴 Cici Chen Mengfei 和 Colette Spriggins。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。他一直在上素描课。他的画相当不错，除了手。他把肩膀、上臂、前臂都画得很好。然后到了手臂末端，总是……
We can't quite put a finger on it.
我们说不出哪里不对。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。